hey 42 here on the 29th of September
1913 a 55 year old German bloke by the
name of Rudolph boarded a steamship in
Antwerp
it was a short overnight hop to his
destination in Harwich on the Southeast
coast of England but when the ship
docked the following day Rudolph was no
longer on board
if you're wondering why you should care
about a random German Vanishing 110
years ago allow me to give you his full
name Rudolf Diesel when he disappeared
from the decks of the SS Dresden in 1913
Rudolf Diesel was one of the most famous
inventors alive and no prizes for
guessing what he invented but here's the
strange part to this day more than a
century later nobody really knows what
happened to him
some people believe he fell overboard in
a tragic accident others think he
willingly jumped
but still others points to tantalizing
evidence that Rudolf Diesel inventor of
the engine that quite literally changed
the world was murdered and that his
killer Got Away scot-free after pulling
off the Perfect Crime as for who's right
let's find out right so you've just got
yourself a brand new phone and you're
looking for the best mobile game to play
well enter raid Shadow Legends with its
awesome visuals and loads of powerful
Champions Ray Shadow Legends is
increasing its roster of awesome looking
Champions with a brand new Rarity
mythical A Step Above Legendary
Champions these new Champions have a
special new mechanic called metamorph
that allows them to change between two
different forms we all have different
personalities like me I have work 42 and
Beach 42 and if you enjoyed that
metamorph wait until you see what the
mythical Champions can do in raid Shadow
Legends they are the most versatile
champions ever seen in raid and you can
tailor your playstyle and create
synergies across both forms their two
forms both use the same artifacts
accessories masteries and blessings so
be careful when you're choosing how to
use them for new players you can get
your hands on stagnite one of the best
epic Champions around as well as a skin
for stag Knight designed by JonTron just
use the promo code JT skin before
October the 7th also check out legendary
champion Sun Wukong raid's take on money
King just log in on seven different days
between now and the 23rd of October to
get your hands on him for free with all
this exciting stuff and more coming to
raid if you haven't started playing yet
then what are you waiting for use my
link in the description or scan my QR
code to get insane bonuses we're talking
an epic Champion Talia from the sacred
order faction and other useful things
like energy refills a skilled home and
an XP booster and thanks again to raid
Shadow Legends for sponsoring this video
despite being as German as beating
England at football Rudolph diesel
wasn't actually born in Germany but
Paris the City of Lights and the
protests was his home for 12 years he
might have stayed there too was it not
for the somewhat awkward outbreak of the
franco-german war a conflict that forced
the Diesels to motor over the English
Channel first London and then back home
to Bavaria in southern Germany
diesel is always a strong student but
his talents transcended the classroom in
fact he was something of a renaissance
man he spoke three languages fluently
read and wrote poetry played the piano
and was consistently top of his class in
every subject in other words he was that
special sort of Arrogant Bastard who
Moved at a party who can do absolutely
everything and when he bends over you
are literally blinded by the sun shining
out of his ass
his strong academic record led to a
scholarship at the newly founded Royal
Bavarian Polytechnic of Munich and it
was there that he met Carl Von Lind a
man who would change his life these days
Lind is best known for founding the
chemicals Giants that bears his name
it's still a Fortune 500 company even
today
but back in 1875 when Rudolf Diesel
arrived in Munich Lind was a talented
young Professor of mechanical
engineering barely into his 30s the two
hit it off almost immediately both were
academically brilliant both had
mustaches that smelled like oil and
chalk probably and both shared a desire
to see their formidable imaginations
realized in the real world
[Music]
while still lecturing a Munich Lind
invented a new kind of machine to
manufacture ice and by the time diesel
graduated in early 1880 Lynn was in the
process of setting up an industrial
Refrigeration plant in Paris being a
talented engineer flew into both French
and German diesel was the ideal person
to help Lind get established it was the
beginning of what was to be an
incredibly successful partnership
between them Diesel and Lynn patented
dozens of inventions over the following
decade as Lind grew his fledgling
company into an international Powerhouse
but diesel wanted more as a Lind
employee all the ideas he came up with
belonged not to him but to the company
he was making a good living sure but his
inventions were making the company
millions and no prestigious promotions
or potent pay Rises would change that
diesel didn't just want a bigger piece
of the pie he wanted his own pie and the
only way to bake one was to start
working on something so far outside his
remit at Lin's that it wouldn't be
covered under the terms of his contract
and you guessed it that's something
turned out to be black currant pie sorry
I meant to say engines my head's just
full of pie metaphors now ironically
enough it was Lind himself he'd first
given diesel that idea back in their
University days diesel had attended a
lind-led lecture in which he learned two
very important things first the steam
engines of the day were lovably
inefficient on average harnessing less
than 10 percent of their total available
fuel energy and second according to
thermodynamic Theory it was possible to
make engines that were vastly more
efficient all diesel had to do now was
figure out how
to begin with his efforts weren't overly
successful actually that's a bit of an
understatement they almost killed him
his early work focused on improving
existing steam engines and doing one
particularly ambitious experiment the
fancy ammonia Vapor engine he just built
excluded in his face
his injuries were so severe he was
hospitalized for months and his eyesight
never fully recovered and you thought
your science teacher was just a knob for
making you wear those silly plastic
goggles
after several other slightly less
catastrophic false starts diesel turned
his attention to developing a new kind
of internal combustion engine he came up
with several important Innovations most
importantly a fuel ignition system that
relied on air compression rather than a
spark plug
the first working prototype of what we
now call the diesel engine was completed
in 1896 and early tests showed it
operated at 26 fuel efficiency making it
more than twice as efficient as any
other engine in existence at the time
the implications were enormous any
industry that used engines I.E basically
all of them could expect gigantic cost
savings thanks to more efficient power
generation not that it was all sunshine
and roses early diesel engines were
plagued with reliability issues and
Rudolph was forced to pay out refunds to
countless unhappy customers as he
desperately tried to improve his design
things got so bad that in 1898 he
suffered a nervous breakdown briefly
ending up in a mental hospital near
Munich
[Music]
by the time the New Century got underway
things were looking up with new and
improved diesel engines being licensed
for use in factories trains generators
and military vehicles both at home in
Germany and abroad
time he boarded the SS Dresden Bound for
London in 1913. Rudolf Diesel had pretty
much made it he'd built a huge Villa for
his family in Munich and had all but
retired living a comfortable life on a
raging torrent of royalties from his
great invention which is exactly why
some people questioned the official
version of events that diesel committed
suicide by jumping overboard on the way
to England in 1913. but if he didn't
kill himself what the hell happened that
night let's start with the facts diesel
boarded The Dresden in the early evening
of the 29th of September 1913.
he had dinner in the ship's restaurant
along with most of the other passengers
then retired to his cabin at about 10 pm
asking a porter for a 6 15 am wake-up
call the next day on the way
when that very same Porter turned up the
following morning to Rouse Diesel from
his dreams
the cabin was empty
a set of pajamas lay neatly folded on a
bed that clearly hadn't been slept in
and the man himself was nowhere to be
found a more thorough search of the
cabin toned up a diary open on the
nightstand next to that day's date was a
small cross the theory goes that diesel
had scribbled it there to Mark the dates
he plans to commit suicide the search
was extended to rest of the ship and
beneath the railings at the very back of
the vessel diesels overcoat and hat were
found in a neat little pile
the international press soon picked up
on the story and to begin with the
overriding response was one of confusion
several of Diesel's friends and
colleagues were quoted in newspapers
expressing their disbelief that he would
ever have considered suicide
but as the days went by with no sign of
him rumors began to leak out about
failed Investments and expensive patent
litigation that had led to severe
financial trouble some reports even
claimed that diesel had left his wife
with a bag full of cash and instructions
not to open it for a week
10 days after Diesel's disappearance a
Dutch ship came across a bloated body of
a man floating in the North Sea the
corpse was in a pretty bad state so the
men decided not to keep it on board but
they did hold on to a few personal
effects found in its Pockets including
including a wallet and a pocket knife
Diesel's son later confirms that these
items belonged to his father
[Music]
now I know what you're thinking the
clothes by the rail the cross in the
diary the body in the water the rumors
of financial trouble what's to talk
about the guy obviously killed himself
but let's not be so Hasty because the
more you examine Diesel's disappearance
the more things start to look fishy for
one thing if he intended to kill himself
that night why buffer asking for an
early morning wake-up call he knew he
wouldn't need and why Mark the date in
his diary committing suicide doesn't
feel like the kind of thing that would
have slipped his mind
then there's the cloves by the rail why
take his hat in coat or Pawn to the deck
in the first place if his plan was to
Simply jump overboard there's also the
question of why he chose that particular
time and place to take his life if
suicide was to plan all along as the
cross in his diary suggests was jumping
off a passenger ship in the middle of
the English Channel really the best
method available to him even the motive
for suicide is a little tenuous whilst
it's true rumors of financial trouble
surfaced after Diesel's death it's also
true that owning the rights to one of
the most important inventions of the
century created plenty of opportunities
to make some fast cash if he really
needed to in fact diesel only boarded
The Dresden in the first place because
he had a meeting in London the following
day to discuss a potentially lucrative
license agreement had that meeting been
successful there would have been a huge
cash injection into his bank accounts
[Music]
okay so if it wasn't suicide what was it
to answer that question it might help if
I tell you exactly who diesel was
planning to meet in London the British
royal Navy
they wanted to license his engine for
use in their submarines
remember this was January 1913 just over
a year before the outbreak of the first
World War
tensions between Britain and Germany
were at an all-time high and here was
Rudolf Diesel planning to sell his
revolutionary invention to the
soon-to-be enemy to help them make
better Subs is it possible the German
government had diesel dealt with to
prevent that deal going through
seen through the lens of murder some of
the stranger details of the case do
start to make sense the early morning
wake-up call he didn't need the timing
just before a lucrative business meeting
even the cross and the diary and the
clothes on the deck what better way to
cover up a murder than to make it look
like such an obvious suicide and it does
feel a little bit convenient that his
body was recovered by those Dutch
Sailors proving he went overboard but
then chucked away again before anyone
had the chance to actually examine it to
determine the true cause of death as for
motives the rumors of financial ruin
only seem to have surfaced after the
event even Diesel's wife and closest
friends knew nothing about them so could
they have been fabricated
okay so there's not actually any hard
evidence that proves diesel was murdered
but then again there's also no hard
evidence he committed suicide nobody saw
him jump interestingly enough it wasn't
only the Germans who had a motive for
his murder
diesel had the rights to an invention
that would go on to revolutionize dozens
of different Industries and that made
him an incredibly powerful man but it
also made him dangerous
one of his design goals when dreaming up
his new engine was to make it capable of
running on almost any fuel his very
first working prototype was just as
happy burning peanut oil as it was
petroleum derivatives and that made the
diesel engine a potentially enormous
threat to the already immensely powerful
oil industry
the brilliant inventor being murdered by
big business or his own government might
sound a little bit Hollywood but things
really do happen governments have been
bumping off their own inconvenient
citizens for as long as there have been
governments and several major oil
companies may have been taken to court
over their suspected involvement in the
murders of climate activists
in the years since Rudolf Diesel's death
the engine that bears his name has gone
on to revolutionize almost every major
industry on the planet and even today
almost 130 years since its invention it
continues to underpin the world economy
as for what happens to the man who
invented it I'll let you decide thanks
for watching
[Music]
and don't forget to use my RAID Shadow
Legends Link in the description or scan
my QR code to get insane bonuses for new
players with an epic champion